Gut.
Schönen guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Ujak.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das
Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, guten Abend.
Ja, einverstanden.
Danke.
Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ja, ich heiße Alfons Wagenkest.
Alfons.
Ja.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen langsam beschreiben?
Vornamen?
A wie Anton, L wie Ludwig, F wie Friedrich, O wie Otto, N wie Nordpol, S wie Samuel.
Ja.
Nachnamen?
W, A, G, E, E wie Emil, N, N, K, E wie Emil, S, C, H, T.
Am Ende ein T.
Okay.
Herr Wagenkest, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ja, ich bin 1.3.1967.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 73.
Wie schwer sind Sie zu sein?
5,70.
Ja.
Okay.
Danke für die Informationen, Herr Wagenkest.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Wie viele Schmerzen haben Sie soeben?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe gestern Schittarkübel aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen haben ganz plötzlich nach dem Abendessen begonnen und sind immer
dauerhaft.
Ich verstehe.
Herr Wagenkest, wo sind diese Schmerzen?
Also Oberbauch, Unterbauch?
Ja, ganz Bauch, Vordertbauch, ganz Bauch.
Ich kann nicht mehr schlafen.
Herr Doktor, ganz einfach.
Ich kann nicht sagen, wo genau die Schmerzen sind.
Alle.
Überall, ja?
Ja.
Okay.
Und strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Die Schmerzen sind nicht.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen bitte genau beschreiben?
Also sind sie eher drückend, stechen, dumpf?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Der Schmerz, ich fühle sich nur drückend an.
Manchmal stich, aber auch.
Okay.
Haben Sie früher eine Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, das erste Mal.
Okay.
Haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Aber ich habe sehr starke Schmerzen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Herr Wagenkirch, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Ja.
Ich denke 10, Herr Doktor.
Viele starke Schmerzen.
Ich habe viele starke Schmerzen.
Okay.
Herr Wagenkirch, Sie haben eine sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ja.
Und diese Schmerzen sind überall am Bauch.
Deswegen möchte ich das Anamnesigespräch unterbrechen.
Okay?
Das kann eine Notfallsituation sein.
Ja.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte das Anamnesigespräch unterbrechen.
Ich vermute, dass der Patient an akutes Abdomen leidet.
Deswegen möchte ich die VITAB-Parameter überwachen und die notfallmäßige Untersuchung durchführen.
Und wenn nötig, werde ich den Patienten zur Operation einleiten.
Aber ich bin jetzt in der Prüfung und ich möchte das Anamnesigespräch weitermachen.
Darf ich?
Ja, bitte.
Okay, danke.
Herr Wagenkirch, Sie haben gesagt, dass diese Schmerzen nach dem Abendessen aufgetreten sind.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verschlimmert?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, ich denke, langsam verschlimmert.
Langsam verschlimmert.
Okay.
Also ich meine, bestimmte Körperhaltung oder Wärmefläche oder Bewegung?
Ich hatte gestern Abend Wärmefläche, aber es hat nichts gebracht.
Okay, alles klar.
Sind Sie schon wegen dieser Schmerzen beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nein, höre ich nicht.
Okay.
Herr Wagenkirch, ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein, höre ich nicht.
Okay.
Aber mein Herz schlägt sehr schnell.
Mein Herz schlägt sehr schnell.
Ich fühle.
Okay, alles gut.
Also meine internste Verbindung ist schlecht, aber wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, haben Sie Herzrasen, richtig?
Ja.
Okay.
Okay, alles klar.
Und leiden Sie unter Brustschmerzen oder einer engeren Gefühle in der Brust?
Nein, höre ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Brustschmerzen.
Das freut mich.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Nein.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich febrikt?
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüterfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Nein, höre ich nicht.
Aber Herr Doktor, der letzte Schuturkang war gestern früh.
Das war alles normal, aber der letzte Schuturkang war gestern.
Okay.
Aber alles war in Ordnung beim Schuturkang, ja?
Ich meine, haben Sie Blut im Stürbemerk oder andere Ferndorgen?
Nein.
Alles ganz normal, aber dann habe ich Probleme.
Okay, alles klar.
Leiden Sie unter Zotbrünen oder Aufstossen?
Nein.
Aber höre ich nicht.
Herr Doktor, die Beschwerden finden gestern eine Gebustagfeier an.
Ich habe dort viele verschiedene Dinge gegessen.
Ich habe zwei Klassen Bier und ein Glas Rotwein getrunken.
Und darunter waren unter anderem Zwiebeln, Kuchen und ein deftiges Buffet.
Viele, viele Essen, Rotwein trinken, andere trinken und Zwiebeln.
Ich denke, viele deftiges Essen.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Wagenknecht, wie ist Ihr Appetit normalerweise?
Haben Sie Probleme?
Ja, ganz normal. Aber seit gestern habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay, und haben Sie in der Lästezeit unwirkulich Ab- oder Suge genommen?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe abgenommen ca. 4 kg.
Aber ich denke, ich habe in den letzten Monaten, oder zwei Wochen, 4 kg abgenommen.
Oder verloren.
Okay.
Herr Doktor, ich denke, ich habe auf den Stress geschoben.
Ich denke, diese Abgenommenheit ist mein Stressgrund.
Okay, also haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Alter?
Ja, aber jetzt rennt man.
Früher habe ich viel Stress, aber jetzt rennt man.
Was machen Sie früher als beruflich gemacht?
Ich war Polizist und Hauptkommissar. Aber jetzt rennt man.
Ich verstehe. Okay, alles klar.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, aber gestern habe ich nicht.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Ja, ja.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Probleme reinzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Seit gestern habe ich dort meinen Bauch aufgebildet.
Fest unter Druck.
Und ich hatte aber seitdem keinen Sturmgang mehr und auch keinen Windabgang.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, gestern.
Okay. Herr Wagenkest, ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, kein Problem.
Okay. Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, Herr Doktor, aber ...
Entschuldigung.
Entschuldigung. Moment. Okay.
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich habe Bluthochdruck seit 10 Jahren.
Ich nehme täglich 8 mg Kandesartan einmal.
Morgens oder abends?
Morgens.
Okay. Und noch etwas?
Ich hatte früher bedsideig eine tiefe Beinwellentrombase.
Deshalb nehme ich Fallitrom zu Blutverdünnen. Morgens eine Tablette ASS 100 mg ein.
Sie nehmen 100 mg morgens ein, ja?
Ja, ja, morgens.
Okay. Und Fallitrom? Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ja.
Fallitrom? Wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Okay.
Vor etwa 10 Jahren hatte ich eine Magenperforation, die operativ versorgt wurde.
Diese Seite oder Damaus würde auf eine Philebografie gemacht, bei der ich einen anaerthrakischen Schock bekam.
Jetzt bin ich gegen Kontrastmittelallergie.
Okay. Herr Wagenkicht, Sie haben gesagt, Sie hatten eine Weinentrombose. Wann war das eigentlich? Wann?
Vor etwa acht Jahren.
Okay, alles klar.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf irgendwelche anderen Medikamente, außer genannten, ein?
Nein, nur ASS und Panzerdrang und Fallitrom.
Okay, alles klar. Sie hatten eine Operation vor 10 Jahren. Ansonsten hatten Sie irgendwelche anderen Operationen?
Nein, das war es.
Okay. Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben eine Allergie gegen Kontrastmittel. Sonst noch etwas? Irgendwelche anderen Allergien?
Nein, nur Kontrastmittel.
Okay. Herr Wagenkicht, rauchen Sie?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Nein, Herr Doktor, ich rauche nicht.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein.
Okay, super. Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, Herr Doktor, aber nicht täglich. Nur pro Wochenende oder pro zwei Wochenende ein Glas Wein.
Ein Glas Wein am Wochenende, ja?
Ja, pro Wochenende oder pro zwei Wochenende.
Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine routine Frage. Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, Herr Doktor, ich habe nicht.
Okay, das freut mich. Herr Wagenkicht, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit, Schlaganfall?
Ja, mein Vater hatte Knochenkrebs im Oberschenkelbereich. Daran ist er leidlich auch gestorben. Meine Mutter ist vor einigen Jahren plötzlich im Schlaf verstorben. Aber man weiß bis heute nicht genau, warum.
Okay, mein Beileid. Herr Wagenkicht, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, gesund.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin vererretet, aber seit drei Jahren von meiner Frau getrennt.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei gesunde Kinder, Herr Doktor.
Herr Wagenkicht, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie jetzt Rentner sind.
Ja.
Also ich möchte nochmal fragen, wie alt Sie sind. Ich habe falsch verstanden, ich glaube.
Nein.
Ich habe 48 verstanden. Ist das richtig oder?
Nein, ich habe 58.
Okay.
48.
Ja.
Okay. Danke für diese Information. Das war sehr wichtig bei mir.
Okay. Ich bedanke mich, Herr Wagenkicht. Das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich mache mir große Sorgen, dass es etwas ernster sein könnte. Kann das etwas gefährlich sein? Habe ich vielleicht einen Darmverschluss?
Ja, Herr Wagenkicht, ohne Therapie kann diese Situation gefährlich sein. Sie haben recht, aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus. Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen. Ja.
Und wir haben viele Erfahrungen über diese Probleme. Wir werden alles für Sie tun. Okay?
Ja, vielen Dank, Herr Doktor. Ist das eine Lebensmittelvergiftung von der Feier gestern?
Also es ist zu früh etwas genau zu sagen, aber ich werde zuerst Sie körperlich untersuchen und ein paar Untersuchungen verlassen und ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, können wir über eine Sicherdiagnose sprechen. Ja.
Was passiert, wenn ich Kontrastmittel brauche? Gibt es eine Alternative?
Auf jeden Fall. Wir haben andere Alternativen. Wir können eine MRT durchführen für Sie.
Also Sie haben eine Kontrastmittelallergie, deswegen werden wir keine Kontrastmittel benutzen. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Ja, Gott sei Dank. Muss ich ins Krankenhaus oder reicht eine Behandlung zu Hause?
Ja, also ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können.
Aber wenn wir etwas auffälliges finden, kann es passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Könnte es sein, dass Sie operiert werden müssen? Aber momentan kann ich leider nicht genau sagen.
Aber wie gesagt, nach der Untersuchung können wir über 100% sicher Diagnose und Therapie Möglichkeiten widersprechen. Ja.
Ja, vielen Dank. Ich warte jetzt.
Gerne. Ich bin gleich wieder da. Ja. Ich verstehe. Vielen Dank.
Okay.
Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön. Herr Alfons Wagenkest ist 58 Jahre alt, 1,73 Meter groß und 75 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Wagenkest stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern bestehender, plötzlich aufgetretener, persistierender,
postprandialer Bauchschmerzen vor, Abdominalschmerzen vor.
Dem Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen nach dem Abendessen aufgetreten und mit der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen seien überall, also das ist eine diffuse Abdominalschmerzen und würden nirgendwo hin ausschalen.
Die Schmerzen seien dumpf und drückend. Der Patient habe ähnliche Beschwerden früher nicht gehabt.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzkala mit 10 von 10 bewertet und der Patient habe gegen diese Schmerzen eine Wärmeflasche benutzt.
Aber diese Behandlungsmethode hätte keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Er berichtete über Tachycardie, Meteorismus und er erwähnte, dass das letzte Stuhlgang gestern früh war.
Die Fragen nach Angina Pectoris, Tussis, Dyspnoe, Nausea, Emesis, Hämatoketzi, Pirosis wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die folgenden bekannt.
Schmerzbedingte Inapetens, Schmerzbedingte Insomnie und Gewichtsabnahme von 4 kg innerhalb von einem Monat.
Zwei Wochen bis einen Monat.
An Erfangenen nannte er seit 10 Jahren bestehende Alterilhypertonie. Vor 8 Jahren diagnostizierte TVT.
Der Patient nehme Candesartan 8 mg, morgens ASS 100 mg, morgens ein und er nehme Phalidrom Tabletten ein, aber die Dosierung sollte geklärt werden.
Vor 10 Jahren zog er sich eine Magenterfolation, die operativ behandelt wurde.
Vor 8 Jahren wurde eine Phlebografie durchgeführt, während dieser Untersuchung eine Kontrastmittel behandelt wurde.
Er hatte eine Allergie, einen anaphylaktischen Schock wegen dieser Kontrastmittel.
Er sei rauch-, Nikotinkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Er trinke ein Glas Wein am Wochenende.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater an Phamurkarzinom verstorben sei.
Die Mutter sei beim Schlafen verstorben. Die Ursache ist unbekannt.
Er habe eine gesunde Schwester. Er sei verheiratet, aber er wohne seit 3 Jahren getrennt.
Er hat 3 gesunde Kinder und wohnt alleine. Er sei Rentner.
Früher arbeitete er als Hauptpolizeikommissär. Er hatte zu viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf ein akutes Abdomen, besonders eine akute mesentrische Ischemie aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter der Füße starker Abdominalschmerzen.
Vor 8 Jahren habe er an TFT gelitten. Er nehme aktuell Verletzung und ASS gegen TFT.
Das ist ein Risikofaktor bei den Patienten.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen akute Pankreatitis und Magenperforation.
Der Patient hatte eine Magenperforation vor 10 Jahren. Das ist auch ein Risikofaktor bei den Patienten.
Und Illus können wir auch als Differenzialdiagnose sagen.
Das letzte Stuhl war gestern früh.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten die VITAL Parameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, vergrößerte Lymphknoten, Druckschmerzen, Abwehrspannung, Loslassschmerzen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Gerindungsparameter, Amylase, Lipase, LDH, Herzentzime, eine Myokatinfakt auszuschließen.
Danach würde ich eine Röntgen des Abdomen durchführen, um die Perforation auszuschließen.
Und ich würde auf jeden Fall eine Abdominalsonographie durchführen, um die mögliche Pathologie genau zu beurteilen, wie z.B. Akute Pancreatitis oder Scholelytiasis oder Akute Appendicitis.
Danach würde ich ein EKG schreiben, um eine Myokatinfakt auszuschließen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich einen MRT durchführen, um die mögliche Pathologie zu überprüfen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und ich würde bei den Patienten einen Venosynzugang legen.
Ich würde flüssig als zuvor Analgetiker verabreichen.
Zuerst sollen wir die Diagnose sichern, danach können wir einen Analgetiker verabreichen.
Ich würde auch ein chirurgisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn nötig, würde ich den Patienten in eine Intensivstation einleiten.
Wenn nötig, würde ich die operative Behandlung planen.
Ich würde auch bei diesen Patienten eine PTA durchführen, um die mögliche Verstopfung der Baucharterien zu beurteilen.
Und gleichzeitig eine Behandlung durchführen.
Oder wir können auch eine Thrombolusetherapie verabreichen, wie zum Beispiel Streptokinase.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Welche Diagnosimetode alternativ ist?
Zuerst eine Röntgenaufnahme.
Sie sagen MRT und Röscher sind andere Methoden.
Zum Beispiel PTA. Sie sagten PTA.
Ich würde ein PTA durchführen, um die mögliche Arterienembolie zu beurteilen.
Das ist die mesenterische Arterien PTA.
Gleichzeitig würde ich eine Therapie, eine Behandlung durchführen, um die Stenose zu behandeln.
Welche Unterschiede bestehen in der Differentialdiagnose zwischen PTA und Mesenterialistischemie?
Bei der Ultraschalluntersuchung können wir eine Blindenverdickung feststellen, eine Freiflüssigkeit.
Auch neben der Blindenverdickung feststellen.
Bei der Mesenterischemie können wir eine Doppelgussonographie durchführen, um die mögliche Stenose bei der Gefäße darzustellen.
In der Anamnese?
Ja, in der Anamnese ist die Charakter der Schmerzen sehr wichtig.
Bei der Apathetik sehen wir eine gewanderte Schmerzen.
Zuerst die Nabel herum und dann der Unterbauch.
Bei der Mesenterischemie sehen wir überall die Füße.
Vielleicht Fieber?
Ja, bei der Apendicitis sehen wir eine Fieber.
Bei der akuten Mesenterischemie ist das nicht meistens.
Ok, bitte erklären Sie, wie eine Ultraschalluntersuchung durchgeführt wird.
Ja, ich werde gerne Sie über die Ultraschalluntersuchung aufklären.
Die Ultraschalluntersuchung gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Verletzungen, Entzündungen, Blutungen, Tumoren oder andere Veränderungen genau zu erkennen.
Wir sollen vorher den Bauch der Körpernregion mit einem Gel einschmieren, damit der Schallkopf fehlerfrei arbeitet.
Die Ultraschallwellen machen die Inderorgane sichtbar und wir können diese Organe auf einem Monitor sehen.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20-30 Minuten und dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen oder Kontraindikationen bei dieser Untersuchung.
Es gibt auch keine Anschränkungen nach der Untersuchung und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Was sind die Behauptungsmöglichkeiten der mesenterellen Ischemi? Sie sagen zum Beispiel, eine syrische Behauptung. Aber andere Behauptungsmethode?
Ja, ich denke wir können bei den Patienten eine Thrombolitiktherapie oder wie steht es?
Die Thrombitome oder Stenibranfation. Die konservative Therapie kann man erst einmal machen.
Die beobachtung und symptomatische Behandlung des Patenten.
Eine wichtige Maßnahme ist Antikorgelang zum Beispiel mit Heparin und weiterer Blutgelände zu verhindern.
Die Thrombitome und Stenibranfation können eingesetzt werden.
Die Syrische Behauptung ist fast die Reaktion nach dem Schaden der Darmabschmiede und um abgestorbenes Gebebeso enthalten.
Die spritzierte Maßnahme ist eine beinhalte Phylistikkaitsubstitution, Schmerztherapie und intensive Überwachung des Patenten.
Wir können die neko-Tische, Teilung des Darms entfernen.
Das war alles.